can I just finish this question we did
actually have an anti if you recall but
I wanted to show you just in case you
wanted another means of doing it you can
do it without a graph if you have the
option and you don't want to graph or
you have time you want to check here's
how you would do it do you remember when
we were finding the point of
intersection between this graph and this
horizontal line do you remember that I
just did this I said that X minus 1 on X
plus 5 equals 5
I said let's find when they actually
equal to each other and because it was
an equation I could just do this you
just multiply by X plus 5 on both sides
and everything just worked its happy
okay however that only works in equation
led you can't do that here for an
inequality you can't just multiply by X
plus 5 does anyone remember the reason
why correct X plus 5 is variable because
X is variable so therefore it changes
sometimes positive sometimes it's
negative which means you don't know what
happens to this inequality okay which
direction does it go so there's a couple
of ways to overcome that the first thing
is you can work out cases but that's
curse and I avoid it wherever I can
the other alternative which is
reasonably straightforward is you
multiply by the square of X plus 5
because that's always positive right so
I can say if I multiply X minus 1 X plus
5 times the square of the denominator
right what that does is it creates a
quadratic over here okay over on the
left hand side you also have a quadratic
like so because you can see you've got
those oh oh sorry that this skillet this
square can sort this one is still there
okay so so now you've got this set up
now at this point what would you do at
this point what would you do you could
expand everything you could expand
everything and then reform a whole new
quadratic rather than two you'd have one
okay that's one option is it anything
else we could possibly do yeah look X
plus 5 is already there
already you know factorize four so we
just need to tweak a little bit to make
it obvious first thing I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do everything on one side so let's
have a let's have everything on the left
so I got this guy and then I've got this
guy now I'm writing it in this fashion
rather than writing squared to make it a
little clearer how to factorize
because you can see oh is this the bad
one you get a month just go skip it I've
got X minus one of these objects over
here and I've got 5x plus five of these
objects over here
so therefore when I take out the factor
of X plus five well I'll and with is X
minus one from here and five lots of X
plus five over here is that okay
so that's less than or equal to zero I
can tidy this up a little bit you can
collect some like terms this is going to
be minus five X so X minus five X will
be minus four X then this will become
minus 25 minus 25 so minus one minus 25
is minus 26 that should look familiar
you remember that number coming up
because we're solving the same problem
we're just looking at it somewhat
differently we want that to be less than
or equal to zero
I can tidy this up a little further so I
can divide this whole thing by negative
two and this whole thing by negative two
and then change the direction of the
inequality because I've divided by a
negative is that okay do you see why I'm
dividing by negative to see this guy in
here it's just a bit messy right so
since I've divided by a negative number
just watch out I've got to change that
inequality now I can simplify I get X
plus five I'm left with 2x plus the teen
and I want that to be greater than or
equal to zero okay now I can do a really
rough sketch of this because this is
going to be a parabola this root over
here will be negative five this root
over he'll be negative six and a half we
already knew that number so it's going
to look something like this I guess
and we want the positive parts that's
this part over here and this part over
here that's a terrible scale you get the
idea okay
so this one's negative five so I can say
X is to the right of negative five or
this one still left that's negative six
and a half now this look should look
familiar with one subtle difference this
is not the answer we got before
what was the inter we got before yeah it
was just greater than it didn't include
this boundary okay so think back why is
it that I include the boundary from here
but actually I need to get rid of it how
do I get rid of it yeah you go right
back to the original question up here
when we did this we actually change the
question ever so slightly we return
something with a denominator into
something without a denominator so right
up here it's actually handy to put in
the domain restriction right X can't
equal negative 5 right off the bat so
now when you connect that piece of
information to this inequality that
tells you the boundary is gone okay and
so now we have the original solution
that we found okay you're happy in that
now just have a look at that this is
still a very involved process so that's
why graphing is in my view graphing is
superior because you have a picture you
don't you haven't changed the problem
into some other problem and then have to
fix it and this is also quite
error-prone like this whole algebraic
process you're sort of asking to make
little numerical errors or sign errors
so I wouldn't choose to do this but you
can and you get the same answer okay